vient de recommencer le sport parce que
je me sentais comme comme c'étaient des
jours sont les dimanches les comptes
jourde escalade reprennent seulement
dans quelques jours mais marouane shaker
et son papa n'en pouvait plus d'attendre
pour s'adonner à leur passion c'est la
première activité un peu plus physique
quand le sperme est d'affaires depuis
le centre d' escalade va pouvoir
accueillir les jeunes par groupe de neuf
mais pour maria cardio la directrice
d'horizon rock à montréal c'était un
véritable everest sanitaires à surmonter
afin d'être prêt à temps premièrement on
a des espaces pour des gels hydro
alcooliques à plein d'endroits dans le
sang et les gens doivent se laver les
mains avant de grimper
après il était de l'autre côté parce
qu'on a deux salles l'autre salle qu on
a repeint complètement 1,9 mais tout va
être ménagé en pensant distanciation les
animateurs ont été formés spécialement
pour respecter les règles sanitaires
comme l'expliquent marie fravalo la
coordonnatrice des quinze jours quand
l'enfant arrive donc il essaie depuis
l'extérieur
il est accueilli par par un salarié donc
il va donc lui faire faire le lavage de
mains prise de température avec un au
laser et puis une fois que ce check in
il est bon on fait les prius de présence
et puis pourront aller sur l'airé ce
pass pour la cour la semaine et attendre
un animateur pour les parents
l'ouverture des quinze jours va être un
véritable soulagement en voyant que les
parrains sont désespérés en ce moment
aussi de trouver une place
grimper le plus haut possible surmonter
les dangers se dépasser voilà une
activité qui va donner une bouffée d'air
frais à tous ces jeunes qui sortent d'un
long confinement
tous les jours les jeunes vont pouvoir
maintenant atteindre leur propre sommet
une manière comme une autre de défier un
virus invisible ici robert frosi radio
canada montréal